This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索数字“2%”。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对算不上安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披重铠。这向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就非得这么做。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“艾伦女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试，对吗？”“我伪造过一次测试。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我的脑子都炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们在二十多岁时遭遇的重大生活改变与过渡，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Thank you for joining us. Today, we're going to jump straight in. No ramble, no dilly-dallying. We're talking about acne. specifically the psychology of acne in our 20s today. This has to be one of my most highly requested episodes. A few weeks ago, I posted that I was doing some research on this topic. The amount of you who emailed me, DMed me, messaged me, was insane
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们剖析二十多岁心理学的又一期节目。感谢你的加入。今天，我们将直奔主题。不闲聊，不磨蹭。我们要聊的是痤疮，具体来说是今天我们二十多岁时痤疮背后的心理学。这绝对是我呼声最高的主题之一。几周前，我发帖说我正在做这个主题的一些研究。给我发邮件、发私信、发消息的人数简直太疯狂了
because I think that this experience of struggling with our skin, struggling with our appearance, is a universal part. of this decade. Everybody has some aspect of themselves that they feel self-conscious about from not feeling thin enough or tall enough or big enough, like each of us harbors an insecurity that we imagine everyone else notices and is judging us on the basis of. Acne is no different and I think is one of the most common insecurities that we face during this period of our lives. For many of us in our 20s, acne is a daily reality about 84% of people between the ages of 13 and 25 are affected by acne according to young medicine that is a sizable majority and yet despite that there is so much shame
因为我认为这种与皮肤作斗争、与外表作斗争的经历，是这个十年中普遍存在的一部分。每个人都有自己感到不自在的方面，比如觉得自己不够瘦、不够高或不够壮，就像我们每个人都怀揣着一种不安全感，以为其他人都在注意到它并以此评判我们。痤疮也不例外，我认为这是我们在人生这个阶段所面临的最常见的不安全感之一。对于我们许多二十多岁的人来说，痤疮是每天都要面对的现实。根据青年医学的数据，13岁到25岁之间约有84%的人受到痤疮的影响，这是一个相当庞大的多数。然而尽管如此，却依然有那么多的羞耻感
and stigma there are entire industries making billions on the backs of our embarrassment no one i think is born hating how their skin looks how their skin turns out we are taught throughout our teenage years and well into adulthood that acne is ugly and that we should cover it up. We need to go on medications that could have long-term health risks just so that we can have that milky, glass-like skin that so few people actually have. I am one of those people who has really struggled with acne for a while. It used to be so terrible. It caused me so much sadness, so much frustration, so much anger in my life, particularly when I was in high school. I distinctly remember showing up at school wearing a full face of makeup,
和耻辱感，整个行业都建立在我们的尴尬之上赚取数十亿利润。我想没有人生来就讨厌自己的皮肤看起来的样子，讨厌皮肤呈现出的状态。我们在整个青少年时期乃至步入成年后都被灌输这样一种观念：痤疮是丑陋的，我们应该把它遮盖起来。我们需要服用可能有长期健康风险的药物，只为了拥有那种极少数人真正拥有的、牛奶般晶莹剔透的皮肤。我就是那种有一段时间饱受痤疮折磨的人。它曾经太糟糕了。它给我的生活带来了那么多的悲伤、那么多的沮丧、那么多的愤怒，尤其是当我在读高中时。我清晰地记得去学校时脸上化了厚厚的妆，
layers of Rimmel foundation, Mabelene, whatever it was, elf foundation that I would get from Kmart, and even more layers of powder. It probably just made it worse in hindsight, but this like practice of sitting down every morning and putting on my makeup over all of my scarring, all of my like pimples, all of my breakouts. It was like protection almost. It was like this way to almost put on a mask and feel less embarrassed about my skin. And the like occasional times I would go in bareface. Anytime someone would look at me or talk to me, I would think that they were just staring at my acne thinking about how gross it was, assuming I didn't wash my face that I ate terribly rather than the truth, which is that it's just, skin condition, it's genetic, it's biological, nothing more. But that built up anxiety and insecurity leaves lasting scars that aren't just skin deep. And the kind of insecurities, more importantly, that really travel with us, even when the acne may fade, even as we age and mature. Even now, my breakups have really been contained. They've reduced a lot in recent years as I think my
涂了多层芮谜粉底液、美宝莲，不管是什么牌子，从Kmart买的e.l.f.粉底液，还有更多层的散粉。现在回想起来，这可能只会让情况变得更糟，但这种每天早晨坐下来，把粉底涂在我所有的痘印、所有的粉刺、所有的爆痘之上的做法。几乎就像是一种保护。这就像是戴上面具、对自己的皮肤感到不那么尴尬的一种方式。偶尔有几次我会素颜出门。每当有人看着我或跟我说话时，我就会觉得他们一定是在盯着我的痤疮，心里想着这有多恶心，以为我没有洗脸、饮食极糟，而不是看到真相——那就是这只是一种皮肤状况，是基因决定的，是生理上的，仅此而已。但那种积压的焦虑和不安全感留下了持久的心理创伤，不仅仅停留在表皮。更重要的是，这种不安全感会伴随着我们，即使痤疮可能消退，即使随着我们年龄的增长和成熟。即便到现在，我的爆痘也得到了真正的控制。近年来它们减少了很多，因为我认为我的
hormones have stabilized. I still find it really hard to go out without makeup on, especially with the podcast. You know, people always ask me when we're going to do full video episodes. And I just can't. I just really can't because I hate to admit it. I'm so self-conscious about my skin and I think one negative comment would absolutely ruin my day. I've seen this happen with so many other creators and podcasters. I always think about Emma Chamberlain and her struggles with her skin and how cruel everyone was around that. And that terrifies me. Those comments always stick with us. They play back in our memory again and again and again.
荷尔蒙已经稳定下来了。我依然觉得不化妆很难出门，尤其是还要录播客。你知道，大家总是问我什么时候要做全视频节目。而我就是做不到。我真的做不到，因为我讨厌承认这一点。我对自己的皮肤超级没有安全感，而且我认为任何一条负面评论都绝对会毁了我的一天。我看到其他许多创作者和播客主也发生过这种情况。我总是想起艾玛·张伯伦以及她与皮肤的斗争，还有周围人对此的残忍态度。这让我感到害怕。那些评论总是挥之不去。它们在我们的记忆中一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地重播。
That one time someone said something that made you realize that they could see what you saw in the mirror, that you had an outbreak, that you had acne, and that it was disgusting and that it was gross in their eyes. I had someone once say to me that I looked like a plague victim when I was like 16 or 17. That was like eight years ago. And you best believe that it stayed with me. perhaps because of that negativity bias we see in psychology, our brains hold on to those mean, mean comments. And besides the impact on our self-esteem and confidence, the bullying we might face, the genuine emotional pain that psychologists are beginning to identify,
就是那一次，有人说了一句话，让你意识到他们能看到你在镜子里看到的东西，你爆发了，你长了痤疮，在他们眼里这是恶心和令人厌恶的。我曾听人说过，当我大约16、17岁时，我看起来像个瘟疫受害者。那是大约八年前的事了。你可以确信它一直伴随着我。也许正是因为我们在心理学中看到的这种负面偏见，我们的大脑紧紧抓住了那些刻薄、刻薄的评论。除了对我们的自尊和自信的影响、我们可能面临的霸凌，以及心理学家开始意识到的真正的精神痛苦之外，
acne can also be physically painful at time, especially if you have very inflamed cystic acne, the severity of that can impact our lives on so many fronts. It's really, really difficult to feel like you have control over this part of your body, the most visible part of your body, and during such a formative period when we already are filled with so much self-doubt, so much expectation to fit in, and very much prone to social comparison, acne does not help the situation on so many levels. It is part of so many of our journeys to self-acceptance, to feeling ugly, to feeling unloveled. at times. So if you are someone who struggles with acne, like myself, who has gone to every
痤疮有时也会带来身体上的痛苦，特别是如果你有非常严重的炎症性囊肿性痤疮，这种严重程度会在许多方面影响我们的生活。感觉自己无法控制身体的这一部分，即身体最显眼的部位，是在这样一个塑造性格的时期，而我们在这个时期已经充满了如此多的自我怀疑、想要融入集体的期望，并且非常容易进行社会比较，在许多层面上，痤疮都无济于事。它是我们许多人走向自我接纳、面对觉得自己丑陋、觉得自己不被爱的心路历程的一部分。
doctor looking for a solution, take an acutane, tried clean eating, every skincare product there is, who maybe has passed their acne days, but worries about flare-ups, the breakout that always happens before like a big event, this episode is for you. Because we're going to discuss just how acne is as much of a psychological condition as it is a demonstration as it is a dermatological condition as well. There are so many interactions between acne and our mental health and vice versa, so let's get into it. Acne is the most common skin condition in the world, but it's mainly experienced by people between puberty and their early 30s, sometimes a little bit after that. The reason we see so many people struggling with acne during this period is because
有时。所以，如果你和少数人一样正在与痤疮作斗争，去每个地方找过医生寻求解决方案，服用过异维A酸（Acutane），尝试过纯净饮食，用遍了市面上所有的护肤产品，或者也许已经度过了长痘的年纪，但依然担心痘痘复发，担心在大活动前夕总会爆发的痘痘，那么这一期节目就是为你准备的。因为我们将探讨痤疮既是一种皮肤病，同时在多大程度上也是一种心理疾病。痤疮与我们的心理健康之间存在着如此多的相互作用，反之亦然，让我们切入正题吧。痤疮是世界上最常见的皮肤病，但它主要发生在青春期到30岁出头的人群中，有时也会稍微延后一些。我们看到这么多人在这段时期饱受痤疮折磨，原因在于
of the underlying hormonal changes we're going through. The hormones most responsible for acne are androgens, which are essentially sex hormones that bring on puberty and fertility. Our prime time to be reproducing is right now. And so that spike in androgen levels is going to be a massive contributor to our predisposition for acne. And honestly, sadly, there's very little we can do to control that. Hormones are a big factor, but acne, whether that is mild, severe, non-inflammatory, whatever it may be. Basically, it comes from oil and dead skin cells that get into our hair follicles that we have all over our face and all over our back, anywhere on the body that has large oil depositories, large natural oil depositories. I'm sure that if you've struggled with acne,
我们正在经历的潜在荷尔蒙变化。对痤疮负最大责任的荷尔蒙是雄激素，它们本质上是引发青春期和生育能力的性激素。我们生育能力的黄金时期就是现在。因此雄激素水平的飙升将成为我们易患痤疮倾向的一个巨大推手。老实说，遗憾的是，我们对此几乎无能为力。荷尔蒙是一个重大因素，但痤疮无论是轻度、重度、非炎症性还是其他什么情况。基本上，它来自于进入我们毛孔的油脂和死皮细胞，毛孔遍布我们的面部、背部，以及身体上任何拥有大型油脂储存库、大型天然油脂储存库的部位。我敢肯定，如果你一直在与痤疮作斗争，
you already know a lot of this, a quick Google search can tell you, All you need to know about follicles and oil glands and skin cells and hormones, the whole cocktail of contributing factors. But also if you are genetically predisposed to acne, if your hormones are raging and unbalanced, you are going to get acne, regardless of how many clean products you put on your face. The thing that I think we don't speak about enough is how much acne is truly biological and not behavioral. that means that when we think about things like clean skin care or like a healthy diet, they're not necessarily going to really help you. For some people they definitely do. But if you're going to get acne, you're going to get acne.
你已经对这些有所了解了，只需快速进行谷歌搜索，就能了解你需要知道的关于毛囊、皮脂腺、皮肤细胞和荷尔蒙的所有信息，以及诱发因素的大杂烩。但同样，如果你在基因上易患痤疮，如果你的荷尔蒙正在失控且不平衡，无论你在脸上涂抹多少纯净产品，你都会长痤疮。我认为我们谈论得不够的一点是，痤疮在多大程度上真正属于生理现象而非行为习惯。这意味着当我们想到诸如纯净护肤或健康饮食之类的事情时，它们不一定会真正帮到你。对某些人来说，它们确实有用。但如果你要长痘，你就是会。
And normally you're going to require some very intense medication to overcome those biological factors. I think despite that knowledge, there are so many other misconceptions people who are have about acne that really contribute to the negative connotations, the negative image of this condition. And also with that, it also contributes to us feeling so bad about what is so normal. These false beliefs around acne confuse us into believing that our acne holds some bigger truth about who we are. If that sounds confusing, let me break this down for you. For a long time, were told, and I remember being told this as a child and as a teenager, that acne came from diet and not washing our skin enough, which we now know are really very minor, maybe contributing
通常你需要一些非常强烈的药物来克服这些生理因素。我认为尽管有这样的认知，人们对痤疮仍然存在许多其他的误解，这确实促成了这种病症的负面内涵和负面形象。随之而来的是，这也导致我们对原本非常正常的事情感到如此糟糕。围绕痤疮的这些错误信仰让我们误以为我们的痤疮蕴含着关于我们是谁的某种更宏大的真相。如果这听起来让人困惑，让我为你剖析一下。很长一段时间以来，我们被告知——我记得自己作为孩子和青少年时也被这样告知——痤疮源于饮食和皮肤洗得不够干净，而我们现在知道这些实际上是非常次要的，或许是诱发因素，
factors, definitely not causing. And so because of this, acne for a long time was associated with being unclean. If you had acne, that must mean that you're unhygienic, that you don't wash your face, that you're eating poorly. I always think back to all those. rom-coms and teen movies we used to watch where a character would like eat a bowl of ice cream or like too much chocolate after a breakup and get a breakout or the gamer guy who ate pizza and he was always depicted as greasy and sweaty and dirty and of course he had acne and these repeated storylines and tropes meant that we have begun to associate acne with slothfulness for lack of a better word slothfulness is such an unsavory,
绝对不是根源。正因如此，很长一段时间里，痤疮都与不洁联系在一起。如果你有痤疮，那一定意味着你不注意卫生，你不洗脸，你的饮食很糟糕。我总是回想起我们过去看的那些浪漫喜剧和青少年电影，其中一个角色会在分手后吃一盆冰激凌或吃太多巧克力然后爆痘，或者那个吃披萨的宅男总是被描绘成油腻、满头大汗、肮脏不堪，当然他也长了痤疮，这些重复的故事线和老套路意味着我们已经开始将痤疮与懒惰联系在一起，找不到更好的词来形容了。懒惰是一种多么令人不快的性格特征，
character trait, even sounds terrible. We all know the negative connotations and we don't want to be lumped into this like characteristic, this category of people. The thing is though, that these myths that acne is like a dirty condition are complete fallacies and a lot of the time they have been sold to us by several industries that benefit from us hating our skin so they can sell us something to make us feel better. I know this sounds a little bit like a conspiracy, but I think the recognition and the moment I recognize this was when I really asked myself, like, if my acne is not painful, if it's not physically disrupting my life, what reason do I have to hate it? Other than that, we have been taught to, especially when you reflect on the fact that
听起来也很糟糕。我们都知道这些负面含义，我们不想被归入这种特性、这类人群中。然而，问题在于，痤疮是一种肮脏病症的这些神话完全是谬论，它们很多时候是被几个行业兜售给我们的，这些行业从我们讨厌自己的皮肤中获利，这样他们就能向我们出售能让我们感觉好一点的产品。我知道这听起来有点像阴谋论，但我真正意识到这一点、认识到这一点的时刻，是我真正扪心自问：如果我的痤疮并不痛苦，如果它没有在生理上扰乱我的生活，我有什么理由讨厌它？除了我们从小被灌输要这样做，尤其是当你反思这样一个事实：
more than 80% of the population is going to experience this at some point in their life. You know, acne has never been normalized at any point in the media or beauty industry until very recently. Every face in every art campaign is airbrushed. No one has skin texture. Movie sets use thousands of expensive products to sell us on this perfect image. We have celebrities having access to face tune as much as the regular person does. And this creates this whole systematic, I think, belief system that acne is not normal, it's bad, and it's ugly, which I honestly disagree with all of those points. What really fascinates me about this culture is when you see those celebrity like before
超过80%的人口将在生命中的某个时刻经历这种状况。你知道，直到最近，痤疮在媒体或美容行业的任何阶段都从未被正常化过。每一个艺术活动中的面孔都是经过美图修饰的。没有人有皮肤纹理。电影片场使用成千上万种昂贵的产品来向我们兜售这种完美的形象。名人使用美图修饰的便利程度与普通人一样高。这创造了一个完整的系统性信念系统，我认为，即痤疮是不正常的、不好的、丑陋的，而我老实说不同意所有这些观点。真正让我对这种文化着迷的是，当你在TikTok或Instagram上看到那些名人的“前后”对比时，当他们展示原始文件
and afters on TikTok or Instagram, when they show the raw file. and then the picture that they actually posted with the flawless skin, I think it just goes to show that even with millions of dollars, sometimes your skin isn't going to do what you want it to. Normal skin is pigmented, it's pimply, it's rough, it's textured, people have little breakouts, people have acne, yet we have been made to feel really ashamed of our skin. It's interesting because as we've seen a rise in social media, I think we've seen a rise in insecurity to do with acne.
然后展示他们实际发布的拥有无瑕皮肤的照片时，我认为这恰恰说明了，即使拥有数百万美元，有时你的皮肤也不会听从你的指挥。正常的皮肤是有色素的、长痘的、粗糙的、有质感的，人们会有小爆痘，人们会有痤疮，然而我们却被搞得对自己的皮肤感到非常羞耻。这很有趣，因为随着社交媒体的崛起，我认为我们看到了与痤疮相关的不安全感的上升。
And we've seen some studies on this, according to the UK Psychology Association, when we have that constant exposure to highly edited and perfected images in media, that naturally creates unrealistic beauty standards. Those standards lead to feelings of inadequacy and self-compairison. There was even a point when the American Medical Association, the literal American Medical Association went to advertisers and said, please stop using Photoshop, please stop using these ways of editing photos because it is making people like mentally unwell.
我们对此进行了一些研究，根据英国心理学协会的数据，当我们持续接触媒体中高度编辑和完美化的图像时，这自然会产生不切实际的审美标准。这些标准会导致不胜任感和自我比较。甚至有一段时间，美国医学会，字面意义上的美国医学会，找到广告商说，请停止使用Photoshop，请停止使用这些编辑照片的方法，因为它让人们在精神上感到不适。
It is painting this very unrealistic representation of beauty that very few people can meet. And if that is all we see, how do we have a fair and realistic point of what is normal? we're essentially set up to hate ourselves because our comparison point is so unattainable. And that might sound very incidental. But over time, this repeated exposure, especially when we're teenagers, especially in early adulthood, it has a cumulative effect. And it makes us feel increasingly embarrassed by the ways in which our skin is not perfect. I think especially in our teen years and in our 20s,
它描绘了一种极不切实际的美丽表现形式，极少有人能够达到。如果这就是我们所看到的全部，我们又如何能对什么是正常拥有一个公平和现实的观点呢？我们本质上被设定为自我厌恶，因为我们的比较基准实在是遥不可及。这听久了可能觉得微不足道。但随着时间的推移，这种重复的接触，特别是在我们还是青少年的时候，特别是在成年早期，会产生一种累积效应。它让我们对皮肤不够完美的方式感到日益尴尬。我认为特别是在我们的青少年时期和二十多岁时，
we don't want any reason to stand out. So when our acne is particularly bad, it becomes a massive source of self-consciousness and it creates a plummet in our self-esteem because it is already so fragile at this stage in our lives when we're just trying to figure out who we are, we're trying to figure out so many other parts of our identity and we have this part of ourselves that people can perceive
我们不希望有任何理由特立独行。因此，当我们的痤疮特别严重时，它就成了自我意识的一个巨大来源，并导致我们的自尊心暴跌，因为在我们生活的这个阶段，当我们正努力弄清楚自己是谁、试图弄清楚我们身份的许多其他部分时，我们的自尊心本来就已经非常脆弱，而我们身上却有这样一部分是人们能够感知到的，
that isn't what we want it to be and we can't control it. we know people may notice it and we worry what they might think when they do. Will they think that you're not attractive? In our 20s, that is a factor that we place a lot of importance on. A lot of us are dating. A lot of us want to find love. And I don't think it's a vain to want to look good and feel good about yourself. In fact, having poor body image has a lot of consequences for our psychological well-being.
它不是我们想要的模样，而且我们无法控制它。我们知道人们可能会注意到它，并且我们担心他们注意到时会作何感想。他们会觉得你没有吸引力吗？在我们的二十多岁，这是一个我们非常看重的因素。我们很多人都在约会。我们很多人都想找到爱。我并不认为想要看起来不错、对自己感觉良好是一种虚荣。事实上，糟糕的身体形象会对我们的心理健康产生很多后果。
In research studies that have been done quite recently, actually, people with acne have repeatedly said that their skin was the major reason they felt unattractive, they felt embarrassed or self-conscious. When we have that constant negative thought pattern in our mind, in our brain, it's going to stop you from doing a lot of the things that you want to do, making new friends, applying for new jobs, dating, participating in, I don't know, hobbies, sporting activities. So many activities that are really, really valuable in this decade that really make this decade. There was one major study in particular on the psychological effects of acne that broke
在最近开展的研究中，实际上，患有痤疮的人一再表示，他们的皮肤是他们觉得自己缺乏吸引力、感到尴尬或不自在的主要原因。当我们的脑海中、大脑中充斥着这种持续的消极思维模式时，它会阻止你做很多你想做的事情，比如结交新朋友、申请新工作、约会、参加诸多的爱好或体育活动。在这个十年中非常有价值、真正成就了这个十年的如此多的活动。曾经有一项关于痤疮心理影响的重大研究，详细剖析了
down the exact impact of this across a number of different areas. This piece of research is honestly magnificent. It's incredible. I'm going to leave a link. And it's one of the first time that researchers have really looked at acne more as a mental condition with emotional symptoms, as much as a physical one, acknowledging that when we see so many poor men, health outcomes associated with a condition or a disorder, it probably deserves some attention. You know, for example, we see increased levels of anxiety, of depression, even psychiatric symptoms. We also see greater levels of social isolation, and that makes so much sense to me. If you don't feel good in your skin, if you don't feel like your external appearance is what
这在多个不同领域的确切影响。这项研究坦白说非常宏大。简直不可思议。我会留下一个链接。这是研究人员首次真正将痤疮视为一种伴有情绪症状的精神疾病，其重要性不亚于生理疾病，并承认当我们看到与某种疾病或障碍相关的许多不良心理健康结果时，它可能值得一些关注。你知道，例如，我们看到焦虑、抑郁甚至精神症状的水平上升。我们还看到更高程度的社交孤立，这对我来说非常合乎逻辑。如果你对自己的皮肤感觉不好，如果你觉得你的外在表现不是你
you would like it to be, that it reflects who you are and who you are not, and that perhaps people are passing judgment, why would you want to leave the house? It takes so much courage to be comfortable knowing that people can perceive you and observe you and think whatever they would like about you. And especially, it takes even more courage when you're not even able to do that for yourself. You're not even able to look in a mirror without feeling a sense of real deep, hatred and hurt. So with that in mind, in 2016, two researchers recruited 100 people who had been diagnosed with acne in the last couple of years and they wanted to understand exactly how this condition was impacting them across 10 different domains of daily life. They followed them for three
所希望的那样，它不能反映真实的你和不真实的你，而且也许人们正在评判你，你为什么还要想出门呢？要泰然自若地意识到别人可以感知你、观察你，并且对你有任何他们想有的看法，这需要极大的勇气。而且尤其是，当你甚至无法对自己做到这一点时，这就需要更大的勇气。你甚至无法照镜子，而内心不感到一种真正深度的仇恨和痛苦。因此，考虑到这一点，在2016年，两位研究人员招募了100名在过去几年内被诊断出患有痤疮的人，他们想要了解这种疾病在日常生活中的10个不同领域对他们产生了怎样的确切影响。他们对这些人进行了为期三个月的追踪。
months. This is what they found. So in 88% of cases, people reported feeling embarrassed or self-conscious due to acne. And those two emotions were directly linked to low self-esteem and self-image. Each of these participants, part of the 88% said the major factor behind why I feel embarrassed in my daily life, why I'm lacking confidence, is my acne. And it was also one of the main reasons why most of these participants actually sought treatment in the first place was because they needed to deal with this insecurity. It was holding them back. 37% of these participants reported that acne influenced how they dressed and how they chose. clothes and outfits that either covered their acne if it wasn't on their face or which they believe
结果如下。在88%的病例中，人们报告由于痤疮而感到尴尬或不自在。而这两种情绪与低自尊和自我形象直接相关。参与其中的每一个人，即88%中的一员都表示，为什么我在日常生活中感到尴尬、为什么我缺乏自信，其背后的主要因素就是我的痤疮。这也是大多数参与者最初寻求治疗的主要原因之一，因为他们需要应对这种不安全感。它一直在拖他们的后腿。37%的参与者报告称，痤疮影响了他们的着装方式以及对衣物和服装的选择，这些衣物要么是为了遮盖如果不在脸上的痤疮，要么就是他们认为
almost like quote compensated for their acne. This is really interesting to me. I'd never heard of this before and I don't think we often correlate acne with a change in the way we dress but I think we don't feel confident in one area we want to make up for or increase our level of confidence in another through our fashion choices. It just shows how deeply ingrained this really, is. Like, it's not just something that's on your skin that you can ignore. It makes its way into your decision making as well. Sixty eight percent of patients reported acne affected their social activities. They said they avoided social gatherings, parties, doing sports, especially during an episode of acute acne flare-ups. They felt that they were making other people uncomfortable or that
几乎可以“补偿”他们的痤疮。这对我来说真的很有趣。我以前从未听说过这个，而且我不认为我们经常将痤疮与着装方式的改变联系起来，但我认为当我们在一个领域感到缺乏自信时，我们希望通过时尚选择在另一个领域弥补或增加我们的自信水平。这恰恰表明了这有多么根深蒂固。它不仅仅是长在皮肤上、你可以置之不理的东西。它也渗透到了你的决策中。百分之六十八的患者报告称痤疮影响了他们的社交活动。他们表示自己会回避社交聚会、派对、做运动，尤其是在急性痤疮爆发期间。他们觉得自己让其他人感到不舒服，或者
people were going to stare at them and that they wouldn't be able to be themselves. This was more so the case in women. There was a higher degree of social anxiety, withdrawal, and I think this pattern and cycle of avoidance contributes further to low self-esteem and of course social isolation. It just becomes, I think, increasingly harder to want to leave the house and want to put yourself out there. So we also, well, this study, it wasn't me, these researchers, these amazing researchers, they also looked at the effect on work and study and they found that 57, half of these participants were seeing acne have an impact on their work, whether that was academic work or career-focused work, a professional job. People were saying, like, I'm so
人们会盯着他们看，而且他们将无法做自己。女性身上这种情况更为严重。她们表现出更高程度的社交焦虑、退缩，我认为这种回避的模式和循环进一步助长了低自尊，当然还有社交孤立。这只是变得——我认为——越来越让人不想出门，不想把自己展现出来。所以我们还，或者说这项研究，不是我，是这些研究人员，这些了不起的研究人员，他们还观察了对工作和学习的影响，他们发现57%（即这些参与者的一半）看到痤疮对他们的工作产生了影响，无论是学术工作还是以职业为重点的工作、专业工作。人们纷纷表示，比如，我被自己的外表困扰得
bothered by my appearance that I cannot concentrate because I'm picking at my skin, because I'm feeling to see if it's gone down, if it's getting worse, I can't stop going and looking in the mirror, I can't stop thinking about what other people are thinking of me. I just want it gone. It's hard to be completely focused or even slightly focused on doing something when you have this big, giant, other ogre thing in your brain, thumping around, taking up so much space. Finally, let's talk about the impact on interpersonal relationships.
无法集中注意力，因为我在抠皮肤，因为我在查看它有没有消下去，有没有变得更糟糕，我忍不住一直去照镜子，我忍不住去想别人对我是怎么看的。我只希望它消失。当你脑海中有这么一个巨大的、像食人魔似的东西在四处踩踏、占据了那么多空间时，要完全专注于某事或者哪怕稍微集中一点注意力都是很难的。最后，我们来谈谈对人际关系的影响。
75% of individuals reported that their acne made it harder for them to date and created difficulties in their interpersonal relationships. And there were a lot of people who said that part of this experience and part of their struggles in these relationships in building new connections is because of previous instances of being bullied or even teased by peers and in some case, relatives and family members. Women yet again felt this more deeply. They felt that having acne made them less attractive,
75%的个人报告说，他们的痤疮使他们更难约会，并在人际关系中造成了困难。还有很多人表示，这种经历的一部分以及他们在这些关系、在建立新联系中的挣扎，是由于以前遭到同龄人甚至是亲戚和家庭成员欺凌或戏弄的经历。女性再次对此感受更为深刻。她们觉得长痤疮让她们缺乏吸引力，
made it harder for them to put themselves out there in a romantic way. I think women are very acutely aware of how much looks matter for them and less so for men. And so, of course, appearance in this aspect is going to be a bigger factor. Not to say men don't also experience it, but I think women really do understand that there are a lot more beauty standards for how we look than how others look. I've seen this with my friends quite a bit where their worth becomes very much tied to how their skin's doing that day. And so they cancel dates.
让她们更难在浪漫方面展现自己。我认为女性非常敏锐地意识到外表对她们有多么重要，而对男性则不然。因此，外观在这方面的确是一个更大的因素。并不是说男性就不会经历这些，但我认为女性确实明白，关于我们如何看待自己，有比如何看待别人更多的美貌标准。我从朋友身上经常看到这一点，她们的自我价值在很大程度上与她们当天的皮肤状况绑定在一起。因此她们会取消约会。
They kind of refuse to believe that anyone could possibly be attracted to them when it's so obvious to be their friend to see how wonderful they are, to see how amazing they are, to never really think about what their skin looks like. It's just, you know, it's just there. It's not a contributing. It's not a changing factor. It doesn't impact how I think of them. But when that is a belief that you're holding so deeply, it's a belief.
她们有点拒绝相信任何人会被她们吸引，而作为朋友，很明显能看出她们有多棒、有多优秀，从未真正去想她们的皮肤看起来是什么样。它只是，你知道，它就在那里。它不是一个诱发因素。它不是一个改变因素。它不影响我对她们的看法。但当你怀抱着这种根深蒂固的信念时，这是一种信念，
it's very hard to feel desirable when you don't really fully love yourself in those moments. The final finding that was so interesting to me because it really affirms a lot of what I believe contributes to the stigma and insecurity about acne is that many of the participants reported that their difficulties in their interpersonal relationships emerged because they were acutely aware that they failed to live up to the idea of perfect, flawless skin, portrayal. in advertising, television, media. This led to a self-perceived reduction in general attractiveness, which we talked about, and an increased fear or perception of being judged, specifically being judged to be unhealthy
当你无法在那些时刻真正完全爱自己时，很难感觉自己是有吸引力的。最后的发现对我来说非常有趣，因为它确实证实了我所相信的大部分导致对痤疮的耻辱感和不安全感的原因，那就是许多参与者报告说，他们在人际关系中遇到的困难之所以出现，是因为他们敏锐地意识到自己未能达到广告、电视、媒体中所描绘的完美、无瑕皮肤的形象。这导致了他们自认为整体吸引力的下降（我们之前讨论过），并加剧了被评判的恐惧或感知，特别是被评判为不健康
or unhygienic. Once again, we're returning to those misbeliefs at the very beginning of this episode that we spoke about. the misbelief that acne is behavioral rather than biological. And when we have this huge accumulation combination of factors, that's going to create a lot of further symptoms of serious mental health conditions. One in particular that I want to talk about is body dysmorphic disorder. They found again and again and again a correlation between people with acne and BDD.
或不注意卫生。再次，我们回到了本集开头讨论过的那些错误信仰。认为痤疮是行为性而非生物性的错误信仰。而当我们拥有大量因素的累积组合时，这将产生严重心理健康状况的更多症状。我想特别谈论的一种是身体变形障碍（BDD）。他们一次又一次地发现患有痤疮的人与BDD之间存在相关性。
And we've spoken about BDD on the show before, but for a refreshing. BDD is essentially a mental health condition characterized by constant worrying over a defect in appearance. We become fixated on our floors and obsessed with correcting them and alongside that we are unable to appraise our appearance objectively. So basically we don't know what we look like because our perception is so continuously influenced by our negative self-beliefs and intense focus and shame and anxiety that we can't see things as clearly as others, as friends, as family can, that it's not that big of a deal, that really it's not that noticeable, that no one is judging you based on what your skin looks like.
我们之前在节目中讨论过BDD，但为了复习一下。BDD本质上是一种以对外貌缺陷的持续担忧为特征的心理健康状况。我们变得对自己的缺点十分执着并痴迷于纠正它们，与此同时，我们无法客观地评估自己的外表。因此，基本上我们不知道自己看起来是什么样的，因为我们的感知不断受到负面自我信念、高度关注、羞耻和焦虑的影响，以至于我们无法像其他人、朋友和家人那样清晰地看到事情，即这其实没那么大不了，真的没那么引人注目，没有人会根据你的皮肤长什么样来评判你。
When you're in the throes of a condition like BDD, it's very hard to see that. And an interesting facet of this that I think really applies to like, the acne and skin space as well is that some people with BDD subsequently develop what we would call an obsession, even an addiction to cosmetic procedures, looking up surgeries, looking up clinics and treatments, investing thousands of dollars in these procedures. Even when the primary issue in this case, the acne is solved. Once again, there is this whole other industry that leverages and profits from our insecurity. I think how we feel about ourselves, some people might call caring about your image vain,
当你处于像BDD这样的病症的发作期时，很难看清这一点。而这其中的一个有趣方面，我认为也真正适用于痤疮和皮肤领域，那就是一些患有BDD的人随后发展出了我们所谓对医美手术的痴迷甚至成瘾，寻找手术方案、寻找诊所和治疗方法，在这些程序上投资数千美元。即使在这种情况下主要的问题（痤疮）已经解决。再次，有另一个整个行业在利用我们的不安全感并从中获利。我认为我们对自己的感觉，有些人可能会认为关心自己的外表很虚荣，
I actually think it has a really profound impact on our mental health. Of course, we are going to be concerned with how our physical form presents, because that is who everyone else in our lives sees. And all of these observations demonstrate just how wide this effect truly spans, even to things that we wouldn't think about. Very few parts of our identity and our daily lives remain untouched. So what I want to talk about next is what to do about it. What do we do when the treatments aren't working when we don't want to go outside?
我实际上认为它对我们的心理健康有深远的影响。当然，我们会关注我们的身体形态呈现出来的样子，因为那是我们生活中其他人所看到的。所有这些观察都表明这种影响的跨度究竟有多么广泛，甚至波及到我们意想不到的事情。我们身份和日常生活的极少部分能不受其影响。所以我接下来想谈的是该怎么做。当治疗不管用、我们不想出门时，我们该怎么办？
And maybe also just offer some encouragements for those of you who are struggling with your emotional and mental health in the face of past or current acne. I don't really want to go through treatment options or anything like that because I'm not a licensed dermatologist. Obviously what worked for me might not work for you, but I do want to explore it. of course the mental and emotional and psychological side of things. So all of that and more after this short break. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
也许还可以为那些面对过去或当前的痤疮而在情绪和心理健康上苦苦挣扎的人提供一些鼓励。我其实不想讨论治疗选项或类似的事情，因为我不是持证皮肤科医生。显然对我有效的方法可能对你无效。但我确实想探讨一下。当然还有心理、情感和心理学层面。所有这些以及更多内容，将在简短的广告之后为您呈现。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主宰健康行业的那些不切实际
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索数字“2%”。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集节目，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某物时。我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间走一遭做一个好人很重要。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
你是因为害怕才成为一个好人的吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。加入我，我是基尔·盖恩斯，我们将进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话，就在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's. Correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她谎言中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战以证明真相。“你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试......对吗？”“我伪造过一次测试。”这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格Greg，一个同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Managing the emotional impact of acne, teenage acne, adulthood acne, I think it extends a lot further than just finding the right treatment. But honestly, that is a good first. step getting onto a medication or seeing a dermatologist reducing your symptoms, reducing your flare-ups. Honestly, it removes our main source of anxiety and insecurity. It is the best place to start.
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，来自美利欧帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。管理痤疮对情感的影响，青少年痤疮，成年痤疮，我认为它不仅仅是找到正确的治疗方法那么简单。但老实说，这确实是一个好的开始。步骤是开始药物治疗或去看皮肤科医生，减少症状，减少爆发。老实说，它消除了我们焦虑和不安全感的主要来源。这是最好的起点。
I think the biggest factor for me was not that it necessarily removed my acne immediately. In fact, it kind of actually got worse in the interim, but it reduced my feelings of hopelessness and not feeling in control. I felt like I was doing something about it. There was a solution. I wasn't going to feel this terrible for so long. I wouldn't have to worry about it as much as I was. I don't want this to sound cheesy, but it just gives me hope.
我认为对我来说最大的因素不是它一定立即去除了我的痤疮。事实上，在此期间它实际上变得更糟了，但它减少了我的绝望感和失控感。我觉得我在为此做点什么。有一个解决方案。我不会这么长时间感觉这么糟糕。我不用像以前那样担心它了。我不想听起来很俗气，但它只是给了我希望。
And although this podcast, we talk about acceptance a lot, we talk about self-confidence, I don't think that you need to be a martyr. I don't think that you need to embrace your acne so that other people feel confident to do so. sometimes if your mental health is really suffering, if you're really struggling, if your self-confidence has never been worse, the best thing for you to do is to find a treatment that works. That can take time though, and in my experience, it also takes a lot of trial and error. Some medications just don't work for some people, or they do work and they have secondary consequences. You know, our acne may settle down, but then we have really bad headaches,
尽管这个播客，我们谈论了很多关于接受的内容，我们谈论了自信，但我不认为你需要成为一个烈士。我不认为你需要拥抱你的痤疮，以便其他人也有信心这样做。有时，如果你的心理健康真的很受影响，如果你真的很挣扎，如果你的自信从未如此糟糕，对你来说最好的事情就是找到一种有效的治疗方法。然而这需要时间，而且根据我的经验，这也需要大量的反复试验。有些药物对某些人根本不起作用，或者它们确实起作用但有副作用。你知道，我们的痤疮可能会平息，但随后我们会有非常严重的头痛，
or irritation, stomach problems, rashes, maybe even an increase in mental. health symptoms like depressive symptoms that might cause us to cease a particular therapy or medication. So in the meantime, what options do we have for living a really good, fulfilling life? Not held back by our parents or by our acne. I think the biggest issue in this is managing self-image and self-esteem. And part of that is starting to normalise acne for yourself. We've spoken a lot about how there is a culture around seeing acne as ugly, seeing it is gross. There are a lot of people out there who don't feel that way and who have made it their mission
或者刺激、胃部问题、皮疹，甚至可能增加心理健康症状，如抑郁症状，这可能导致我们停止特定的治疗或药物。所以在此期间，我们有什么选择来过上真正美好、充实的生活？不受父母或痤疮的阻碍。我认为其中最大的问题是管理自我形象和自尊。部分原因是从开始为自己正常化痤疮。我们讨论了很多关于如何看待痤疮是丑陋的，认为它是恶心的文化。有很多人并不这样认为，并把这当作他们的使命
to ensure that this next generation of people grows up without those negative connotations. Start following acne positive influences. We spend a lot of time on social media. It gives us a lot of subliminal messages on how to think, how to feel, many other factors. and when you are constantly in an online space of perfection, flawless skin, face tune, whatever it is, that is not going to do well for you when it comes to your social comparison. And it's not to say that you're going to compare yourself to these other people and be like, oh yeah, their acne is so much worse than mine. I feel better.
确保下一代人在成长时没有这些负面含义。开始关注痤疮积极的影响者。我们在社交媒体上花了很多时间。它给我们提供了很多关于如何思考、如何感受以及许多其他因素的潜意识消息。当你经常处于一个完美的网络空间、无瑕疵的皮肤、美颜滤镜或任何东西中时，这对你的社会比较是没有好处的。这并不是说你会把你自己和其他这些人进行比较，然后觉得，哦，是的，他们的痤疮比我的严重得多。我感觉好多了。
No, it's about seeing people who you actually can relate to reflected back at you on a platform where you spend so much time. also try and buy from brands that have a no Photoshop policy. I love these kinds of brands. You can find a whole list online. It means that you can shop on their sites without feeling like everything is so heavily photoshopped. Just expose yourself to media where you see characters who look like you. I feel like people have been saying this for so long when it comes to representation in so many
不，这是关于在一个你花了很多时间的平台上看到你真正能产生共鸣的人反映在你身上。也尽量从没有Photoshop政策的品牌购买。我喜欢这种品牌。你可以在网上找到整个列表。这意味着你可以在他们的网站上购物，而不会觉得一切都被严重修图了。让自己接触到能看到长得像你的角色的媒体。我觉得人们在很多方面一直在谈论代表性
other forms. It is so important to see people. who you can relate to even if they're fictional because it means that your story, your narrative, your experiences are validated and you don't feel as alone in what you're experiencing. The one movie that I think does this really well, specifically around Acme, is Lady Bird, the Sersha Brunin, Greta Gerwig movie. Absolutely amazing. Euphoria as well. I know these are very like teen focused. girls.
其他形式。看到能引起共鸣的人非常重要，即使他们是虚构的，因为这意味着你的故事、你的叙事、你的经历得到了验证，并且在你经历的事情中你不会觉得那么孤独。我认为在这方面做得很好的唯一一部电影，特别是关于痤疮的，是《伯德小姐》，西尔莎·罗南和格蕾塔·葛韦格的电影。绝对太棒了。还有《亢奋》。我知道这些非常注重青少年。女孩。
That show is so, I can't watch it without seriously wanting to like slap every single one of those characters in that TV show. But it's all about being like, this is a realistic depiction of what the average 20 year old looks like. We're so inundated with perfectly altered, filtered, edited skin that many of us also adopt those same strategies of swiping through filters or covering out. blemishes covering our scars. We are also subjecting ourselves to the illusion of perfection whilst showing ourselves that it doesn't exist. If that makes sense. It's sometimes hard to realize
那个节目太……我无法不认真地想要扇那个电视节目里的每一个角色一巴掌。但这一切都是为了让人觉得，这是对普通20岁年轻人长相的现实描绘。我们被完美修饰、过滤、编辑过的皮肤淹没，以至于我们中的许多人也采用了同样的方法，通过滤镜滑动或掩盖瑕疵，掩盖我们的疤痕。我们在向自己展示它不存在的同时，也让自己屈服于完美的幻觉。如果这说得通的话。有时很难意识到
that if you're editing your photos from a place of insecurity, there are so many other people who are doing that as well. If you are never going to put your face on social media without makeup on, think about all the other people who are doing the same thing. I'm so guilty of this. I said this the other day in a video, but I only do videos with a full face of makeup on. I often think, oh yeah, this won't get as much engagement. People aren't going to like this content. People, I'm definitely going to get cruel comments if I do this without makeup on, if they can see what I really look like right now.
如果你是因为不安全感而编辑照片，还有很多人也在这样做。如果你永远不在不化妆的情况下将脸发到社交媒体上，想想其他也在做同样事情的人。我对此感到非常内疚。我前几天在视频里说过这个，但我只拍画着全妆的视频。我经常想，哦，是的，这不会得到那么多的互动。人们不会喜欢这个内容。人们，如果我不化妆，如果他们能看到我现在的真实长相，我肯定会得到残酷的评论。
So, like I said before, it's not that you have to be a martyr. It's not that you have to go out there and reveal all of your insecurity for the world in order to be part of the normalization process. it really is about what makes you feel best and creating an online environment in which you see yourself reflected back at you you're not faced with like the literal propaganda wall of perfect skin trying to sell you a new product that is going to be so freeing. I think a small step to accepting acne as well is thinking about what small activities you can do in your day-to-day life without makeup, with a bare face. Challenge yourself. Get used to being a little bit uncomfortable. Get used to people.
所以，就像我之前说的，你不需要成为烈士。你不需要为了成为正常化过程的一部分而走出去，向全世界展示你所有的不安全感。这其实关乎什么能让你感觉最好，并创造一个网络环境，让你看到自己被反射回来，而不会面对像推销新产品的完美皮肤那样无休止的宣传墙，那将是无比自由的。我认为接受痤疮的一个小步骤也是考虑你可以在日常生活中做哪些不需要化妆、素颜的小活动。挑战自己。习惯于感到有点不舒服。习惯于人们。
Maybe they're looking at you, but why does it matter? Why does it matter? It really doesn't matter. Like, what is that going to mean for your life? Does it mean that is them in your acne? Is that going to mean that a family member drops dead tomorrow? Does it mean that your boyfriend's going to break up with you if someone sees your acne? Does it mean you're going to fall ill, full seriously ill? No. If someone makes a judgment based on literally what is skin deep, quite literally, so skin deep, so shallow, that says so much more about them than about you. I just want to remind you of that fact. It's scary sometimes. I used to use makeup as a crutch for my insecurity all the time, but over, as you keep repeating this practice, you get used to feeling.
也许他们在看着你，但那又怎样？为什么重要？真的没关系。那对你的生活意味着什么？这意味着他们在看你的痤疮吗？这是否意味着某个家庭成员明天会突然死去？如果有人看到你的痤疮，这意味着你的男朋友会和你分手吗？这意味着你会生病，生重病吗？不。如果有人仅仅根据皮肤表面的东西做出判断，字面上来看，太肤浅了，这更能说明他们的问题，而不是你的问题。我只想提醒你这个事实。有时这很可怕。我以前总是把化妆当作掩饰不安全感的拐杖，但随着你不断重复这种练习，你就会习惯这种感觉。
a lot more unburdened by the opinions of others, and you'll start to notice that you're too busy to even care. I also think it's a part of this is addressing confidence more generally, and the way that I always like to talk about this is, what are you doing when you feel your best? What activities make you feel amazing regardless of a bad skin day? What activities make you feel more in control of your health, even when your skin is being frustrating?
不再那么被别人的意见所累，你会开始发现你忙得甚至不在乎。我也认为这的一部分是更普遍地解决自信问题，我总是喜欢谈论的方式是，当你感觉最好的时候你在做什么？无论皮肤状态多差，什么活动能让你感觉棒极了？即使在皮肤令人沮丧的时候，什么活动能让你觉得更能掌控自己的健康？
What activities take you aware, from how your skin is looking. More so what put you, what activities put you in a state of just like completely forgetting to think about it. Do more of those things. You need more of that energy in your life. You will be amazed at how little you start thinking about it
什么活动能让你摆脱皮肤外观的困扰。更确切地说，是什么活动能让你进入一种完全忘记去想它的状态。多做那些事情。你的生活需要更多那种能量。你会惊讶于当你开始用让自己感觉良好的事情填满你的时间，并开始更全面地解决你的自信和健康问题时，你开始去想它的次数是多么少。
when you start filling your hours with things that feel good for you and you start addressing your confidence and your health more holistically. the other tool that I have in my self-confidence toolkit is the what-if game now we've spoken about this before if you've heard this I'm going to just say it again for the people who haven't oh my god I sounded like such as teacher just then that is so embarrassing but anyhow the what if game this is a like a tactic that is taken from cognitive behavioral therapy and CBT cognitive behavioral therapy essentially its whole premise is if we change our cognitions we can change our behaviors and we can
自我自信工具箱中的另一个工具是“如果”游戏，我们以前谈论过这个，如果你听过的话，我将为那些没有听过的人再重复一遍。天哪，我刚才听起来就像个老师，太尴尬了，但无论如何，“如果”游戏，这是一个从认知行为疗法（CBT）中提取的策略，认知行为疗法基本上它的全部前提是，如果我们改变认知，我们就可以改变行为，我们就可以
change how we see the world and our attitudes and how we act. We can apply this to our acne. Acne and our anxiety around our acne and our appearance always starts with a thought and the thought always starts with a what if. That's how you can identify an anxious thought. Let's start. Let's play the game. Let's play the what if game. What if they see my acne? Okay, answer the question. If they see my acne, they might think I'm ugly. Okay, what if they think I'm ugly? If they think I'm ugly, they might not like me. What if they don't like me? Well, if they don't like me, then maybe someone else, maybe other people won't like me. Maybe they don't want to be my friend. Maybe they won't want to date me. Okay, what if they don't want to date you? Well, well, then what? Well, if they
改变我们看待世界的方式、态度以及我们的行为方式。我们可以把它应用到我们的痤疮上。痤疮以及我们对痤疮和外表的焦虑总是从一个想法开始，而这个想法总是从一个“如果”开始。这就是如何识别焦虑想法的方法。我们开始吧。我们玩这个游戏吧。我们玩“如果”游戏。如果他们看到我的痤疮怎么办？好吧，回答这个问题。如果他们看到我的痤疮，他们可能会觉得我很丑。好吧，如果他们觉得我很丑怎么办？如果他们觉得我很丑，他们可能不会喜欢我。如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？好吧，如果他们不喜欢我，那么也许其他人，也许其他人不会喜欢我。也许他们不想和我做朋友。也许他们不想和我约会。好吧，如果他们不想和你约会怎么办？那么，然后呢？好吧，如果他们
don't want to date me, what? They don't want to date you. And that's fine, because it doesn't say anything else about the other people who do or don't want to date you? And if your response to that, what if they don't want to date me? What if they don't like me is, well, no one will ever like me. That is a thought where you can, I think, objectively look at it and realize that it's irrational and realize that it comes from a place of fear. The what if game basically looks at our thoughts and proves to ourselves without undermining those thoughts that they are not correct, that they are coming from a place of self-doubt that they are our inner critic speaking very loudly. And it's also speaking over the parts of us that are rational, that are gentle, that are kind to
不想和我约会，又怎样？他们不想和你约会。这没关系，因为这并没有说明其他想或不想和你约会的人有什么问题？如果你对“如果他们不想和我约会怎么办？如果他们不喜欢我怎么办？”的回答是，好吧，没有人会喜欢我。这是一个你可以客观地看待并意识到它是非理性的想法，并意识到它来自于恐惧。其实“如果”游戏基本上是审视我们的想法，并在不贬低这些想法的情况下向自己证明它们是不正确的，它们来自于自我怀疑，是我们的内心的批评者在大声说话。它也在压制我们内心中理性的、温和的、善良的部分
ourselves, that understand that once again, if a person sees you as no more than what your skin looks like, that is the epitome of a superficial attitude, a superficial attitude towards connection towards other people. You don't want them in your life. You'll be okay without them. I also think it's important to address the mental health perspective of this as well and the mental health consequences. You deserve to have a very fulfilling and happy decade, your 20s, but also a happy life in which you get the opportunities that everyone else is having, the experiences that everyone else is having. If you're finding that your skin is really holding you back, is really keeping you in an isolated, unhappy place. Therapy is amazing for that. I'm going to say it
自己，明白再次说明，如果一个人只看到你的皮肤长成什么样，这就是肤浅态度的化身，对人际关系的肤浅态度。你不需要他们进入你的生活。没有他们你也会过得很好。我也认为从心理健康的角度和心理健康的后果来解决这个问题也很重要。你理应拥有一个非常充实和快乐的十年，你的20岁，但也拥有一个快乐的生活，在其中你可以获得其他人正在拥有的机会，其他人正在拥有的体验。如果你发现你的皮肤真的在阻碍你，真的让你陷入孤立、不快乐的境地。治疗对此非常神奇。我要说
again and again and again. Having someone who is a neutral party to just talk through who kind of is like you're paying to tell you the truth is so powerful. I also think they'll help you see a lot of perspective. I was talking to a friend of mine who's a therapist and who does a lot of things about body dysmorphia, but also just like appearance-based counseling and appearance-based work. She was like the amount of times that I have people, full adults who are coming into my office and crying because of their skin is ridiculous. Ridiculous knowing that they shouldn't be, but like she just never expected that that would be such a point of insecurity for so many people because once again we don't talk about it.
一遍又一遍又一遍。有一个中立的第三方来倾诉，有点像是花钱让他们对你实话实说，这是非常有力量的。我也认为他们会帮你看到很多观点。我和我的一个朋友谈过，她是一名治疗师，做很多关于身体变形的事情，但也做很多基于外表的工作。她说，我办公室里有很多成年人，因为皮肤而哭泣的次数简直荒谬。荒谬，明知不该如此，但她从未料到这会成为这么多人不安全感的来源，因为我们再次不谈论它。
But this is your reminder. Your very loud reminder, there are so many other people dealing with this. That's not to devalitate what you're going through. It's more to show you that in this place of fear, this place of anxiety, this place of frustration, you are not alone in that. A lot of people spend a lot of time worried about
但这提醒了你。这是一个非常响亮的提醒，有很多人正在处理这个问题。这并不是要贬低你的经历。这更多的是向你展示，在这个充满恐惧、焦虑和沮丧的地方，你并不孤单。很多人花了很多时间担心
whether their skin looks good today, what's going to happen when it looks bad, how they can fix it, how they can have it under control, the doctor's appointments they need to go to, the photos of themselves that they see that they hate, that was a huge thing for me. I hated seeing photos of myself when I had bad acne. There's literally no photos of myself from back then. And I'm really disappointed by that. It's such a shame because I don't get to see myself grow up and grow through that.
他们的皮肤今天看起来好不好，当它看起来不好时会发生什么，他们如何解决它，如何控制它，他们需要去的医生预约，他们看到的他们讨厌的自己的照片，这对我是件大事。我讨厌看到自己长严重痤疮时的照片。从那以后，我几乎没有自己的照片。我对此感到非常失望。这太遗憾了，因为我没有看到自己成长并经历这一切。
I don't have that whole chapter in my life. And although it was a hard chapter because I was so insecure, I did make it through. obviously here I am and I think that it taught me a lot about recognizing that your worth is not always tied to what you look like and that you can fake confidence even when you have this thing that really is holding you down and making you feel bad about yourself so I really hope that you have enjoyed this episode I hope that you've learned something about the psychology of acne I'm going to link that study, I think that you should read it if this is something that you relate to, just to understand that there is a whole community of people out there who have similar fears. And it's so fascinating
我生命中没有那一整章。尽管那是一个艰难的章节，因为我很不自信，但我还是挺过来了。显然我在这里，我认为这教会了我很多关于认识到你的价值并不总是与你的外表挂钩，即使你有这种确实在拖累你并让你对自己感觉不好的东西，你也可以伪装自信，所以我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我希望你对痤疮的心理学有所了解。我会链接那个研究，如果这是你感同身受的事情，你应该去读读它，只是为了解外面有一个由有类似恐惧的人组成的完整社区。这太令人着迷了
to realize that for how much we stigmatize and create like an aura of shame around acne, it is such a common skin condition. And it's time that we normalize it, but also that we recognize that it's not just physical. It's also mental and it's also emotional. So thank you again for listening. If there is someone who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it with them. And also feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening, I read all of your reviews. Sometimes when I'm feeling a bit sad, I go in and I have a look, and they are so encouraging. So thank you so much for all of the love. I always say this, but if you do have an episode suggestion, I get a lot of my ideas, a lot of my inspiration from
意识到尽管我们对痤疮污名化并创造了一种羞耻感，但它是一种非常常见的皮肤病。现在是时候让我们将其正常化，同时也要认识到它不仅仅是生理上的。它也是心理和情感上的。所以再次感谢大家的收听。如果有人需要听到这个，请随时与他们分享。也欢迎在苹果播客、Spotify或您收听的任何地方留下五星评价，我阅读了你们所有的评论。有时候当我有点难过时，我会进去看一看，它们是如此令人鼓舞。非常感谢你们所有的爱。我总是这么说，但如果你有剧集建议，我的很多想法，很多灵感都来自于
what you guys, the listeners are thinking about, are talking about, are experiencing in your own lives. So shoot me a message on Instagram at that psychology podcast, and we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
你们，听众们正在思考的、正在谈论的、在你们自己的生活中正在经历的事情。所以在Instagram上@that psychology podcast给我发条消息，我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我是我的播客《2%》的主持人。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的迹象。让自己经历一些困难，你会走出阴霾。成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方的TWA%。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
对1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人Kear Games主持的《用硬方式学习》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装就像穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《用硬方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。